What if I told you that I wanted you to meet my brother who is an only child?
My guess is you would stop and you'd think, wait a minute.
If you have a brother then by definition he can't be an only child.
And if someone is an only child then that person does not have a brother.
The idea of a brother who's an only child is impossible.
Some people make the same kind of arguments against the existence of God.
Meaning when we look at certain attributes of God that God is all good, God is all
-powerful we look at the presence of evil some people say the existence of God is
just as absurd and crazy and unbelievable and in fact logically contradictory
as the idea of a brother who is an only child in fact formally let's write down
exactly what this argument looks like so we can kind of dissect it and break it down
and here's three premises and the conclusion
One would be, if God is all
-powerful, he
could stop evil.
Let me just ask you a question for a second.
How many of you believe that God is all-powerful?
Seriously, by show of hands, how many of you?
Okay, all of you do. Second premise, if God is
all good, he would
stop evil.
Now how many of you believe that God is all good?
Let me see your hands. You believe God is omnibenevolent, all good, okay, good.
Third, evil exists.
Now, how many think evil or at least evil acts really happen and that they're real?
By show hands, how do you agree?
Okay, again, all of you do. So if these three premises are true, what falls for the
conclusion necessarily? Then what?
Then therefore an
all-powerful, all
-good God
does not exist
simply put god does not exist
if these three premises are true this conclusion follows
some people will see this just as straightforward and as powerful of excluding the
idea of god as the idea of a brother who is an only child so if we want to show that
this conclusion doesn't follow and show that it doesn't disprove god what do we have
to do
Ella we need to prove that one of them is false okay good at least in principle we
have to show that one of these premises is not true so if we can show that one of
these premises is not true then the conclusion about god not existing doesn't follow
all right so the key is to show that at least one of these premises is not true now
eastern religions like buddhism hinduism and others of the sort will actually
typically begin with a third premise we've studied eastern religions and pantheism
anybody know what would a pantheist say about the third premise
Preston pantheists don't believe in good or evil so they'll deny that premises
good yeah you're exactly right because remember in pantheism all is one so
distinctions between good and evil yesterday and today me and you mind and matter
all these distinctions are artificial so they actually quote solve the problem of
evil by saying there is no such thing as evil now logically speaking does this get
us out of the problem of evil and it does it actually logically removes this, but
let me ask you a question. Is that a meaningful, substantial way to solve the
problem of evil by actually just saying it's not a problem at all?
Does that resonate in your heart?
When you look at the world and your experience, is it fitting to you to just say
evil doesn't exist?
When I look at history, I look at my life, and I look at our culture it sure seems
to me that the reality of evil acts is about as real as anything
so as Christians and those of us committed to following where reason leads
getting rid of evil and saying it doesn't exist sure seems like too
high a price to pay so let's take a look at the other two premises and see
if that's more promising so let's consider premise number one if God is all powerful
he could stop evil. Now, all of you agreed that God is all-powerful, but we have
to ask a more basic question. What do we mean when we say God is all-powerful or
omnipotent? Can God do anything?
Do you think God can do anything we can conceive of?
Could God make a rock so big he can't move it?
People raise that challenge against God and say, wait a minute, if he can make a
rock so big and can't move it he limits himself if he can't make a rock so big he's
limited therefore god is not all powerful these are ways that are meant to trick and
confuse what we mean by god being all-powerful so let's see let's explore this
premise a little bit further i actually brought with me a paper clip and i want to
know Jenna i'm going to call on you all right i will give you an a in my class you
don't have to write any more papers don't take any tests if you can simply take
this paper clip and bend it into a square circle.
No, I can't do that. You can't? You don't want to try?
No. I'll give you a college scholarship as well.
Don't want it? No. Alright, so maybe she just doesn't have enough power.
So I need somebody, maybe a football player.
Zach, I'm going to pick on you.
Since you're a football guy, lift a little bit of weight can you bend that into a
square circle i don't think it's possible
can't do it no even with all that might i don't think so are you sure you don't want
to try
now why not so we went we added more power to the mix and you say it's still not
possible could the strongest person on the planet make this in a square circle
No. Could God turn this into a square circle?
The answer is no. Now think about it.
By definition, a circle has no points.
If it has any points, it's not a circle.
By definition, a square has four points.
If it has more or less, it's not a square.
A square circle cannot exist. Even God can't make a square circle.
Now before you freak out and say, wait a minute, Mr.
McDowell is limiting God's power.
No, the question is what do we mean when we say God is all-powerful?
And theologians have wrestled with this for centuries.
You know what they mean when we say God is all-powerful?
We mean God can do everything that can be done.
So think about that.
If power can do something, then God can do it.
but power alone can't it doesn't matter how much power you have there cannot be
a square circle so there actually are some things god can't do this isn't a
limitation upon god it's a recognition that some things in themselves are impossible
and cannot be you might say wait a minute there's other things
that i can do that god can't so think about it how many of you ever have told a lie?
Let me see your hands. How many of you have lied to me?
No, I'm kidding. You don't have to raise your hands for that one.
We've all told lies at some point in our life.
Now can God tell a lie? Do you know in the book of Hebrews it says God cannot lie?
Now think about that. Does that mean you can do something that God can't do
therefore you're more powerful than God?
Does that follow?
Probably not. What is a lie? It's not a strength.
it's actually weakness. It's an imperfection.
So God can't lie not because he lacks power but because God is morally perfect.
So notice when we say God is all-powerful, we don't mean God can do anything we can
just conceive of. We mean God can do everything that power can do that is consistent
with his moral nature but here's the key that this challenge misses even
God can't make a world with beings who are genuinely
free and then him force us to always do what is good
because if God forces us to always do what is good we're not what
we're not free and if we're truly free then God is not doing what
forcing us to always do what is good.
So yes, God is all powerful. Yes, God can and will stop evil.
But logically speaking, God can no more make a world with genuine
free will where humans make meaningful choices and then him
turn around and force us to always choose what is good.
So let's take a look at the second premise.
If God was all good, he would stop evil.
Now think about your life for a second.
When you see suffering and evil, maybe it's somebody drowning.
Maybe it's somebody being bullied or taken advantage of.
If you had the power, wouldn't you step in and stop it?
Of course you would. Yet every day certain kinds of evils happen and God doesn't
stop them. Does that make you better than God?
At least that's how the argument goes.
So let me ask you a question. Can you think, at least off the top of your head, any
reason why God might allow suffering and evil?
Anybody? Khalil. Maybe God has a reason for it.
Okay, good.
You're on the right track. Maybe God has reasons for the evil and suffering that we
see in the world. Now let me follow up with that question just to think about it.
You don't have to answer it. if god has reasons should we expect to
always know god's reasons i
mean think really think about it if god had reasons or a purpose in the way you
hinted for allowing evil should we expect to know god's reasons
so if i told you there was an elephant in this room how quickly could you just
determine if that's true or false pretty quickly says great you would know instantly
By doing what?
By just looking around. What if I said there's a flea in this room?
And Zach goes, nope, I can't see when you're wrong.
What would we think? We'd say, okay, wait a minute.
You could see an elephant instantly if it's in here because of its size, but a flea
would take a lot more search.
You wouldn't expect to be able to see a flea just from your seat looking around.
Well, look, if God is all-powerful, if God is self-existent, God is
eternal. He sees the past and the present and the future and how every decision
we make affects other people.
Should we honestly expect to know why every time God allows suffering and evil?
I bet if we went around the room and we had time, could any of you think of times
where you've seen suffering and evil and good has come out of it?
Sure. We can all think of times where there's suffering and evil, and good comes out
of it. Well, let me tell you a story.
A good friend of mine who's actually one of the smartest people that I know,
absolutely brilliant, naturally brilliant.
I've talked to him about God for probably 10 years, and he has little interest.
It's more about making money, being popular, and success.
And one day he called me out of the blue.
And in this call, he essentially, I picked up the phone, and I was surprised it was
him. And he goes, hey, you teach your students apologetics, right?
I said, yes. He said, how do you know God exists?
Where do you begin?
And I about dropped the phone because I was so stunned that he was calling me.
And I said, I'm happy to help you.
This is what I do. This would be fun.
But why are you calling me now? And he paused and he said, I have a friend who at
that point was in a life-threatening accident.
He said, it's shaken and woken me up to my own mortality.
I need to know if God exists and I need answers for eternity.
And we went and talked and laid through a lot of the apologetics and material
conversationally that you have been learning in this class.
But notice what happened. He was going through his life, worried about making money,
worried about what's right in front of his face, being happy.
All of a sudden some suffering and evil happened.
It shook him up and it made him think about eternal questions in a way that he
hadn't before.
If there really is eternal life, and this life is about knowing God,
can you see how maybe God, because He is good, would allow not
cause, but allow something like that to happen maybe because
God is good and he understands the depth of our depravity and how distracted we get
with our own lives and how we get caught up in sin maybe God actually allows there
to be some evil and some suffering to draw us to him because maybe like you said
God has a bigger plan the question is, will we trust him?
C.S. Lewis once said, God whispers in our pleasure, but he shouts
in our pain. Pain is God's megaphone to arouse
a deaf world.
What was he saying? He's saying that in our pleasure and our joys of life, sometimes
we think about God, but maybe because God is good and because
he's so powerful. He can even use our pain and our suffering and the evil in the
world, turn it towards good and draw us to rely upon and trust.